in for the panel if they are pro-choice
are they pro-death penalty for criminals
um if you
hold this if you don't hold this ethic
then why is it okay to kill a baby and
not a criminal
so you guys pro-death
penalty good question good question
yeah my pro death penalty
shout out to you man i mean i think a
lot of people would say it depends on
the crime right because it's like let's
be honest if you steal a pack of crisps
from your local corner shop and someone
rats you out you're going to say yo chop
that guy's head off
that's obviously this is contextual yeah
but for me like honestly if there was a
way to 110
with no deviation
tell someone done a crime and and this
is the most egregious crimes against
humanity like
just i don't know like
mass grape or stuff along those lines
and you know without a shadow of a doubt
that that person did it i don't care
kill that [ __ ] that is what it
is
so i'm for that but again my stance on
the abortion issue
only relates to that two percent other
than that i don't like
i'm pro-life all the way do you know i
have a quick question freddie
because you said you have a sister i got
two sisters i've got two sisters yeah as
well by the way
do you think if we didn't have sisters
we like would you still
be would you still have that similar
mindset or is it because is it because
like
okay
like i
men we have to protect women yeah i'm
just no i'm just asking and i don't
understand that we have to protect women
that's it that's just part of our
responsibility as men absolutely so
obviously having sisters helps i've
grown up with them and obviously i'm
someone that likes to read and learn so
i see what happens out there i see what
sort of crimes benny can commit which is
why it's our responsibility to help
women but
yeah i think my my viewpoint
it should be consistent with it because
women are women regardless whether i
have a sister or not
so what about you guys death penalty yes
or no
it depends on the crime yeah so you'd
say yes because essentially you think
some crimes yeah
you know i'll be real
i'll say
again this is kind of from my religious
background but
i
i would say yes i am and also annoy
because i'll be
it sounds it sounds corny but it's like
i
who am i to basically decide whether
someone should live or die you know i
mean to me like only god has that you
know god has that program
how can i think about people that touch
kids exactly
and this is what i mean i personally if
it was me i'd be like yeah like stone
him chop him down like whatever but like
i guess the religious side of me would
be like
i think you also have to take into
account as well that
it depends on whether i'm the one making
that decision or not i'm happy to speak
as someone who can speculate as to
whether that's right or wrong but if i
was the person that says oh i'm don't
have to push the button to administer
that death i probably would have a
different outlook on it
i'm not the one committing that i'm not
the one murdering this person for
whatever crime that they committed so
it's easy to have that standpoint of
someone who's not going to actually push
the button or because so probably even
tougher question like could i do it if
that person was of those crowns
whenever you're in the shoes really so
it's like when you go back to abortion
it only depends when you're in those
shoes
when it's you
it's okay to a standpoint and like think
of something like someone else's shoes
but and it's you it's different in it so
i'm probably so myself i'm pro-life and
i look at that question when you talk
about as a criminal like should they be
possibly prosecuted by death penalty
penalty if like their crime is so
egregious and i'm like
my stance is on the religious basis who
am i
to take life
when i didn't give it
do you know what i mean so when i hear
like everyone like
well in this case it's okay in this case
it's not we're all looking at how we
emotionally feel about a certain
situation and i think when you put
emotions into a playwright
someone's emotions could be in higher
regard than the next person's does it
make it right
which is why you have to be 100 sure
because even if you're 100 sure if i'm
100 sure that this person stole
a million pounds
like a million pounds to someone else
might be like
life-changing that's like another person
that i'm to who's the worst of the so
what so touching kids isn't universally
egregious i'm not saying it isn't i'm
just saying
taking life is one thing yeah yeah okay
i understand but see the way i look at
it is incentives
and as a society when you when you up
the punishment for something less people
do it true true so what
oh come on no no
i agree
more so than anything i'm like the
people take
committing these egregious crimes i
think there's a certain level of mindset
that they've been through or a level of
trauma that they've gone through that
has put them in a place where they're
gonna commit that crime at some point i
some right some but
i think there's a group that would be a
bit scared if they knew that was the
punishment
and to me that would be saving children
because the majority of kids that get
sexually abused go on to do the same
thing true so i just have a special
hatred in my heart
for people that touch kids i think
that's disgusting
do you think they deserve the death
penalty oh yeah okay that them
yeah like i think that's the worst crime
you could possibly do this i agreed do
you think imagine a powerful question do
you think mattresses does have the death
penalty as well
yeah
i'd say no to that yeah i think i think
it
like the serial killers that sort of
thing
yeah
but what about if you take someone's
life yeah that's what they're gonna ask
no no no context you've taken someone's
life yeah
is it intentional
well no no some people do it in
self-defense yeah so like that would be
called manslaughter but like i'm saying
take taken someone's life it was
intentional let's say um someone
um cheated with your
it was an act of love like someone
cheated on you with cheating is
different from men and friends
but then
let's go anyway
it doesn't mean the same thing you go
out to i don't know i'd be like you know
that's okay yeah that would be okay
that's it you should have given the eggs
on
why it worked
it was a good difference
yeah but like let's say
they deserve the death penalty like if i
did that yeah i would deserve the death
penalty because what my emotions made me
commit murder someone take someone's
life away from their family
that's horrible that's a horrible thing
to do 100 sure i agree but death penalty
i don't know the thing is i don't think
these things can be seen as like dick
they're cut they're not like cutthroat
they're not cutthroat you can't see them
as universal things i think when it
comes to these because humans are just
so different there has to be context you
can't have a